ja ob Karl Lauterbach noch weiterhin
Bundesgesundheitsminister wird das kann
ich natürlich nicht beurteilen also aber
wenn es um den Heeren Grundsatz
politische Verantwortung für gewisse
Dinge geht dann müsste natürlich
irgendjemand in der deutschen Politik
mal endlich Verantwortung übernehmen
das könnte theoretisch auch hier in
sparen sein aber der ist ja bekanntlich
nicht mehr an sondern wurde mit ihrer
Partei abgewählt also der ist schon weg
da bleibt eigentlich nur der jetzige
Bundesgesundheitsminister übrig
das interessante an
Bundesgesundheitsminister Karl
Lauterbach ist natürlich dieses
heute journal Interview am vergangenen
Sonntag das war ja ein Ergebnis einer
ZDF Dokumentation über Impfschäden
und wo er dann tatsächlich gesagt hat er
hätte also über diese impfschiene und
Impfnebenwirkungen schon die ganzen
Jahre über Bescheid gewusst das ist ja
nicht so dass er neu Erkenntnisse haben
kann das wollen wir niemand verweigern
aber Karl Lauterbach war der Prototyp
des des Mannes der eigentlich alle was
im Schäden und ähnliche Dinge betraft
klein geredet hat dann finde ich nicht
und ähm ja darüber können wir dann
gleich reden und ähm und das ist genau
das das entscheidende Problem dass jetzt
auf einmal etwas aufploppt was schon
länger bekannt war und das zweite was
Karl Lauterbach eigentlich was mit noch
weiter erstaunte Karl Lauterbach hat er
ziemlich exakt gesagt also 1:10000 hat
er irgendwo so eine Zahl genannt also
sehr gering ne sondern das dann die
Mediziner auf welcher Datengrundlage er
das gemacht hat ist mir nicht ganz klar
weil eigentlich haben wir so eine
miserabel Datenlage dass wir sowohl dass
wir bei über Impfschäden oder gar nicht
richtig Auskunft geben können mit dem
was sie in Deutschland haben aber
gemeinsam rein ins Heute schneiden das
ging vor allem auch um die Aussage er
hätte die Impfung als nebenwirkungsfrei
beschrieben was Karl Lauterbach heute
dazu sagte schauen uns jetzt mal an
naja das war eine Übertreibung also die
ich da einmal in einem missglückten
Tweet gemacht habe aber es war ja nicht
grundsätzlich meine Haltung ich hatte ja
sehr sehr häufig vorher auch schon zu
den Nebenwirkungen der Impfungen
Stellung genommen sind zum Beispiel sehr
Klima auch häufig danach noch gesagt es
gebe kaum oder praktisch gar keine halt
mehr oder weniger nebenwirkungsfrei
haben sie danach in der Fernsehsendung
von Anne Will noch mal gesagt ich habe
es ja eben gesagt also die Zahlen waren
wir ja die Zeit bekannt die sind auch
relativ stabil geblieben äh diese
Impfstoffe sind ja weltweit eingesetzt
worden 1 zu 10.000 das hätte also die
Zahl über 1:10.000 das ist jetzt hier
unser großes Thema der Umgang des
Gesundheitsministers mit den im Stehen
übrigens sie haben gerade eben gesagt er
hat da im Prinzip mehr oder weniger eine
riesenwende hingelegt er hat erst gesagt
es ist alles nebenwirkungsfrei und jetzt
gibt er etwas kompliziert dann doch zu
ja es gibt sie die impfen kann man sagen
er hat bewusst die ihre geführt ich weiß
gar nicht ob er das bewusst macht oder
sich selber einfach in ihre führt weil
das Groteske ist ja dass er jetzt
irgendwo etwas behauptet was seine
gesamten Kommunikationslinien in die
ganzen zwei Jahren komplett widerspricht
also ich habe mit Kollegen von der Welt
Tim rödenas haben wir damals zum
Beispiel darüber berichtet über eine
über die Daten der BKK Provita der hatte
die
betriebskrankenkassendaten ausgewertet
und der Kollege der Vorstandsvorsitz
oder der Vorsitzende dieser
Betriebskrankenkasse wollte dass da mit
dem paul Ehrlich Institut
diskutiert dazu ist gar nicht gekommen
der wurde entlassen aufgrund von
massiven Druck wie kann man überhaupt so
etwas machen wie kann man das in Frage
stellen das war schon das war schon das
einzige Argument das wäre querdenkerei
Geschwurbel und weiß der Teufel was
alles ich kann mich an diese Diskussion
weil ich habe mich ja daran mir selber
aktiv beteiligt kann ich mich wirklich
noch sehr gut erinnern und jetzt kommt
Karl Lauterbach mit genau dieser These
und was wir damals zum Beispiel genauso
schon geschrieben haben das ist also
immer noch so wir haben deswegen so
schlechte Daten weil man am Beginn der
Pandemie folgendes hätte machen müssen
oder wenn ich jetzt ein bisschen
rechtlich
Sozialgesetzbuch 5 Paragraf 295 also das
ist total wichtig übermittlungspflichten
und Abrechnung bei ärztlichen Leistung
dann hätten wir das damals zum Beispiel
bei jedem geimpften auf die
Krankenkassenkarte eingetragen der ist
geimpft oder nicht geimpft da hätten wir
bei gewissen Krankheitsbildern zum
Beispiel reale zahlen gehabt wie
entwickeln die sich bei geimpften wie
entwickeln die sich bei ungeimpften das
was wie beim paul Ehrlich Institut
bekommen haben in den ganzen in diesen
zwei Jahren da kann jeder jetzt
irgendwie eine impft Nebenwirkung mehr
melden aber das Problem ist das ist
überhaupt keinen Ansatz noch niemand
statistischen Hinweis darauf gibt ob das
jetzt
epidemiologisch statistisch mit der
Impfung Zusammenhang stehen kann oder
nicht also im Grunde laufen wir im Nebel
herum und das ist natürlich der einzige
Skandal also dass wir überhaupt nicht in
der Lage sind aufzuklären und dann am
Beispiel wäre es besser macht die Ideen
zum Beispiel
es gab ja es gibt ja ein paar
Krankheiten die sind tatsächlich bekannt
also Myokarditis sinusven Thrombose und
so etwas bei astrazenika und was machen
Ideen als sie da das mitbekommen haben
aufgrund ihrer statistischen Auswertung
die funktioniert haben haben gemacht
genommen das war irgendwie eine april
oder so etwas 2021 die Deutschen haben
es erst im September gemacht aber ich
würde jetzt noch mal doch widersprechen
also erstens finde ich die die
Argumentation völlig ab sozusagen ja der
Span hat das damals falsch gemacht und
jetzt muss der Lauterbach dann deswegen
zurücktreten also entweder sparen oder
Lauterbach in der man muss den Kontext
sehen die damalige Situation war das
völlig idiotische Impfgegner Thesen
aufgestellt haben die völlig absurd
waren und ich kann dir vorstellen dass
jemand wieder Lauterbach dann sagt gegen
diese Imke hoch gefährlich und bloß
nicht impfen und so gesagt hat die ist
nebenwirkungsfrei jeder der sich
wissenschaftlich auskennt jeder der sich
Wissenschaft als Kind weiß sowas gibt es
nie eine ein
Medikament das keine Nebenwirkungen hat
hat das ist ein Grundsatz der
Pharmakologie
Wissenschaft und die Signalwirkung in
der Pandemie
korrigiert
er hat es ja auch korrigiert und ich
fand viel wichtiger und im Nachhinein
jetzt zu sagen wir haben da viel zu
wenig Daten es war damals so wir wissen
das noch alles war damals so dass die
Leute beängstigt waren ich bekommen
keine Impfung die einen ja die anderen
waren gegen die Impfung in dieser
Situation wo man ganz schnell also
normalerweise wenn Impfstoff 10 Jahre
lang entwickelt was hätte es in
Deutschland für einen Aufstand gegeben
wenn man 10 Jahre gebraucht hätten und
da gab es dann natürlich auch Dinge ich
stimme Ihnen ja insofern zu dass man
wahrscheinlich der ist RKI z.B Robert
kocht hätte viel mehr Untersuchungen
machen müssen die z.B steht auch
versucht hat zu machen das ist gut aber
auch das ist nicht gelaufen man hat
versucht sehr schnell
eine eine dramatische Situation die wir
die die Menschheit noch nie hatte zu
managen und dass da auch mal Fehler
vorkommen würde ich zu billigen aber
Lauterbach hat sich immer bemüht die
Öffentlichkeit auch über den Stand der
Wissenschaft zu informieren das ist und
entschuldigt sich dann dafür dass er
sagt nein
also erstens es geht nicht um die
Situation jetzt Ende November zwei oder
dezember 2020 bei der Einführung der des
Impfstoffes und die ganze Diskussion
davor hatten wir noch gar keine
Impfstoff sondern es geht darum oder so
etwas dass ab Ende 2011 Herbst 2021 mit
dem nächsten Lockdown auf einmal diese
infrage und zwar nur in Deutschland in
dieser Gewalt zu einem docmatischen
Thema gemacht worden ist wo sogar über
impfpflichten diskutiert worden ist es
ist weder in Norwegen noch in Schweden
oder sonst wo nur in Deutschland und
Österreich kam dieses Thema Impfpflicht
auf die Werte was völlig absurd war weil
für die Impfpflicht das überhaupt weder
keine epidologische immunologische und
sonst welche Begründung gut das ist
aber nicht einfach nein die versuchten
das im Bundestag nur was nur an der CDU
und Teilen der FDP gescheitert ist die
SPD und Grüne hätten das einfach
durchgezogen und da kann sich doch kein
Auto machen heute nicht hinstellen ja
das hat wollten wir ja gar nicht äh ist
ja Unsinn man kann ja seine
bundestagsreden sich noch anhören und
das ist genau das entscheidende Problem
es wurde diese Impfung in einer Art und
Weise
ideologisiert ich habe das ganze mal am
Anfang der Pandemie schon politische
Virologie genannt wo es überhaupt nicht
mehr um Medizin gehen ja aber wenn dann
auf beiden Seiten ja es gab auch
nirgends so absurde Gegner wie in
Deutschland
nur
danach möchte ich gerne
also dass ich ich warum konnten die
Jugend auf die Schnapsidee nicht mit
irgendjemanden der in einen Topf zu
werfen der vielleicht irgendein Unsinn
Gegner wie Impfgegner gab es nicht werde
aber ich will nicht ganz so sicher sie
kennen vielleicht nicht gedacht
schon verteidigt zu dieser Zeit würden
sie das heute mit dem Wissen von heute
anders beurteilen das ist ja immer die
gleiche Frage es gab keine Blaupause
dafür das ist Nummer 1 Nummer 2 ich
meine es geht ja hier bei Lauterbach um
was anderes und da geht's auch nicht um
die Frage Jens Spahn ja oder nein es
geht um die Frage des aktuellen
Verantwortlichen wenn ein Politiker
jemanden hinter die Fichte führt muss
ich einfach sagen gleitet die komplette
Glaubwürdigkeit der Politik darum geht
es und das ist das Problem hier
selbstverständlich kann er am Schluss
sagen oh ich habe mich geirrt ich habe
neue Erkenntnisse da ändere ich was aber
dass er sich hinstellt und sagt er
eigentlich habe ich es ja vorher gewusst
und zwar anders das ist natürlich nicht
in Ordnung ich muss auch dazu sagen es
hat mich ja Familie ja selbst auch
getroffen mein Vater war im Pflegeheim
die ersten Impfstoffe kamen November
Dezember für die Pflegeeinrichtung mein
Vater ist gestorben im Januar weil er
nicht geimpft worden ist weil ist genau
eine Woche zwei zu spät war da wird man
auch nie rausfinden war es jetzt alleine
das waren es andere Faktoren das wissen
wir einfach nicht das kann man nicht
sagen und zur damaligen Zeit war ich
tatsächlich der Auffassung dass man
zumindest in Pflegeeinrichtungen bei den
ganzen vulnerablen aber auch bei der
Frage derer die sie pflegen darüber
nachdenken muss ob man sie nicht
verpflichten muss zeitlich verpflichten
muss weil sie ja mit vulnerablen zu tun
haben dort eine Eindämmung vorzunehmen
nicht für alle das kann man streitig
Stellen
ich würde sagen
Gesundheitsminister sein
anerkennt ist oder die gibt es würden
sie dann müsste er normalerweise jetzt
die Konsequenz sehen und sagen ich habe
euch damals hinter die Fichte geführt
und dann sagen das wars fassen es geht
nicht um die Frage Formulierung gewähren
gesagt das stimmt
sind müssen sie damit leben was Sie
gesagt haben aber ist natürlich Unsinn
nebenwirkungsfreies Unsinn bei jedem
Medikament bei jeder Impfung kann man
gar nicht sagen also ich rede ja nicht
über sie und sie müssen ja auch gar
nicht zurücktreten
Funktion von Karl Lauterbach und bitte
das ist es jetzt natürlich doof doof das
geht gut bin dann heißt das sagt er
jetzt so ich würde es bei meinen genauso
sagen und ich kann ihn nur sagen auch
eine Manuela Schwesig unmöglich und bei
vielen anderen auch das schadet der
politischen er hat der ganzen Kaste das
schadet uns allen wenn nicht in diesen
Funktionen konsequent gerade Linie auch
was gesagt wird und natürlich zugibt ja
das war aber so Moment wir müssen
schauen ganz klar man kann ein Wort
falsch sagen wir reden hier schon von
Menschen die Unterschieden leidigen
Leben zerstört ist und ja darum kämpfen
dafür Frank auch Anerkennung zu bekommen
und das ist aufgrund der Datenlage
zunehmend schwieriger weil man eben
nicht mehr nachvollziehen kann und einen
langen bürokratischen Weg gehen muss
damit dieser im Schaden auch anerkannt
wird ein ganz ganz erstes Thema bei dem
vielleicht nicht einfach nur mal ein
falsches Wort fallen darf ja genau und
deswegen verstehe sagten ebenso schön
naja da haben Corona Gegner also diese
Impfgegner die haben da ganz komische
Behauptungen aufgestellt und da musste
der Lauterbach ja mehr oder weniger
sagen das ist nebenwirkungsfrei damit
das habe ich nicht gesagt er hat einen
Fehler gemacht das habe ich aber eben
gesagt daraufhin durfte im musste er das
so sagen damit die Leute okay das das
mitziehen und das finde ich eben das
Schlimme wir sind in dieser sind alles
verteufelt worden Menschen auch dass sie
sagen die haben gesagt das ist
gefährlich wie kann man sowas sagen das
ist Meinungsfreiheit in Deutschland dass
Menschen Angst hatten vor dieser Impfung
dass keiner wusste wie diese Impfung
ausgeht dass keiner Wurst und zu dir
immer gesagt wenn wir keine Impfpflicht
bekommen wenn wir alle sterben so hat es
Lauterbach ich sage es mal übertrieben
immer wieder betont es war eine
Panikmache werden alle Angst ich war
auch froh dass sie im Stoff aber ich bin
auch dreimal geimpft ich habe Corona
auch gehabt im wir sehen doch heute das
ist doch total Quatsch gewesen ist eine
Impfung
wir müssen immer dazwischen dann aber
wirklich Unsinn
dass sie sagen Lauterbach kann das
einfach mal sagen es ist ein falsches
Wort
verlässt die Sendung glaube ich
ja das ist sehr schade bleiben Sie bei
uns nein natürlich sehr schade für
unsere Runde da es geht hier in dieser
Sendung und dafür das muss ich Ihnen
liebe zuschauen und Zuschauer sagen ganz
klar darum dass wir hier eine offene
Debatte führen dass hier jeder sagen
kann was er denkt gerade das Thema der
Pandemie ist ein hoch emotionales Thema
ganz ganz viele Menschen haben gelitten
und ich glaube wir müssen alle daran
arbeiten da transparent zu werden und da
auch aufzuklären und genau das soll hier
in dieser Sendung auch passieren
deswegen finde ich es persönlich
besonders schade wenn jemand nicht mehr
Teil dieser Diskussion sein möchte das
respektieren wir ich hoffe meine gestern
trotzdem weiterhin Freude daran diese
Debatte weiterzuführen vielleicht wollen
sie aufrutschen damit ich hier nicht so
einsam Sitze das würde mich freuen von
Herr Lutz
ich finde das sehr bedauerlich denn ich
denke es ist ein ganz ganz wichtiges
Thema wir sprechen weiter darüber und
ich hätte mir auch gewünscht dass wir
darüber ganz offen diskutieren können
deswegen bedauerlich aber wir machen
weiter
du hattest das Wort du hast gerade
gesagt das muss ich auch selber noch mal
schauen was du gerade gesagt hast red
noch mal von vorne du deine Gedanken es
ging im Prinzip darum dass es viele
viele Menschen gibt die darum kämpfen
ein Impfschaden anerkannt zu bekommen
die Informationen darüber fehlen und für
die das natürlich nicht einfach nur ein
Wort war dass man falsch gesagt wurde
sondern es geht darum dass man vertrauen
auch in die Politik vielleicht dadurch
verloren hat absolut und es war ja
damals so und darum ging es mir gerade
auch ich habe jetzt die Reaktion noch
überhaupt nicht verstehen können das ist
ja einfach nur der Punkt ist weil er
sagt na ja der Lauterbach musste mehr
oder weniger lügen weil die Menschen
sich sonst nicht hätten impfen lassen
aber das ist doch das geht doch so nicht
nee aber es geht ja so nicht und am Ende
ist es ja so ähm die Menschen hatten zu
Großteil einfach wahnsinnige Angst vor
dieser Pandemie vor dieser Krankheit die
keine einschätzen konnte es war
natürlich gar keine Blaupause wir hatten
alle Angst wir waren ja alle dankbar
dafür absolut aber man muss sich doch
dann ehrlich machen und wenn dann die
Wissenschaft nach und nach neue
Erkenntnisse hat dann muss man sich
ehrlich machen auch sagen Dinge falsch
gelaufen sind dass er sich jetzt ehrlich
macht ist ja gut aber dann muss auch die
Konsequenzen daraus tragen Herr
Lauterbach und das ist genau der Punkt
den hat man man hat diesen Eindruck er
sagt das jetzt so bei the way und
Aussehen wusste ich das und das waren ja
Daten aber es wäre alles nicht so
schlimm weil er eins zu 10.000 wenn
überlegt wie viel Menschen geimpft
worden sind und möglicherweise jetzt
lebenslang mit Schäden zu kämpfen haben
und man durfte ja fast gar nicht sagen
dass man nach der Impfung Schäden hatte
dann galt mir ja eben gleich als
möglicherweise Corona Leugner schwoben
oder sonst was also es Bedenken und
Ängste der Menschen durfte man ja gar
nicht mehr aussprechen und das finde ich
eben so schwierig man muss doch genau
wie das gerade gesagt haben offen mit
der Diskussionen die war aber nachher
moralisiert man durfte gar nicht mehr
Angst äußern Kritik äußern dann war mein
automatisch irgendwo auf der falschen
Seite und das finde ich halt sehr sehr
schwierig heute kriegen diese Menschen
im Nachhinein natürlich ein Stück weit
recht aber sind sie natürlich nichts
wenn Sie heute mit schweren Folgen zu
kämpfen
statt führen wir da diese Debatte die
wir auch in dieser Sendung gerade
gemerkt haben auch schmerzhaft auch
emotional ist weil es eben um das Leben
meisten Menschen geht um das Schicksal
von Menschen wie viel Aufarbeitung
müssen wir da in Deutschland leisten
natürlich muss es komplett aufgearbeitet
werden auch richtig ist dass man
ehrlicherweise erst nach zehn Jahren
feststellen kann wie ein Medikament
richtig viel funktioniert das ist alles
richtig ich behaupte sogar selbst wenn
Lauterbach damals alles auf den Tisch
gelegt hätte hätte sich so vieles nicht
geändert wir hatten damals Situationen
da hieß es mir machen keine
Massenveranstaltungen mehr dann als es
etwas weniger wurde fC Köln wir lassen
nur geimpfte ins Stadion lauter solche
Dinge es gab ja auch Voraussetzungen die
man erfüllen musste um überhaupt am
Leben wieder teilzunehmen das wäre
vielleicht in new yorsen wenn man gesagt
hätte das kann gefährlicher sein anders
gewesen nur wir wissen doch alles gibt
auch jetzt Medikation die gefährlich
sind und trotzdem werden sie in Anspruch
genommen deshalb glaube ich ist das gar
nicht so der große Unterschied und ich
finde es auch schade dass er gegangen
ist wer aus der Tür rausgeht muss
nämlich irgendwann auch wieder
reinkommen und
vielleicht bin ich dazu sehr Demokrat
unterhalten uns dürfen unterschiedliche
Meinungen haben und jetzt sagen was
andersrum wäre Lauterbach jetzt nicht
Minister würde ich nicht überbewerten
aber weil er Minister ist und weil er in
der Zeit ja auch schon da war hätte er
hätte sich nichts abgebrochen schon
damals alles sagen können und das ist
das Problem er hätte sich nichts
abgebrochen er hätte vielleicht auch
einiges verhindern können denn man muss
sagen es gab mehr oder weniger eine
mittelbare Impfpflicht die schon gesunde
Menschen dazu gedrängt hat sich impfen
zu lassen wir haben gerade hier über den
Druck gesprochen der da aufgebaut wurde
denken Sie an die Menge an wirklich
Versterbenden an Toten und wie die
gestorben sind ich glaube ich bleibe
dabei so viel anders wäre es gar nicht
geworden
aus Italien noch Italien zum Beispiel
dass sie auch zum Teil eine auf einer
viel Interpretation einfach Berufen also
die das hatte gar nicht eigentlich gar
nichts mit der dramatische Situation zu
tun das wurde nur in diese Bilder hinein
interpretiert was man nicht so einfach
machen kann ich bin ja der Meinung oder
so etwas ob Lauterbach zurücktritt das
hat immer etwas mit dem Rückhalt in der
eigenen Partei zu tun aber der Bundestag
natürlich ja das kann ich unser Kopf in
angucken aber der Bundestag kann
natürlich zum Beispiel eine
endkommission einrichten um genau diese
Aufarbeitung ein auf politisch
wissenschaftliche Ebene einfach mal zu
machen und dann müssen wir uns jetzt
wirklich etwas
bisschen wirklich Wasser in den Wein
gießen in Deutschland haben wir eine
Pandemie Politik gemacht die einfach
fachlich wissenschaftlich schlecht war
also auch im Vergleich zu anderen
Staaten es war eben so dass zum Beispiel
das war kein Zufall dass in einer
Staaten niemand über die Impfpflicht
geredet hat es natürlich gab es dort
auch Beschränkung aber zum Beispiel Karl
Lauterbach wiederum und das hat gar
nichts damit zu tun der war ja so eine
Art nebenminister schon in Zeiten
der großen Koalition hat sehr entspannt
noch Minister war offiziell der hat dann
zum Beispiel hat Karl Lauterbach dem
anders technell das ist der Chefin
Podologe in Schweden hatte den Rücktritt
empfohlen wegen der angeblich
katastrophalen schwedischen Politiker
gut aber die Schweden haben damit
natürlich solche macht und wir haben
einen anderen Weg beschritten nein durch
solche sehen ja das ist aber zum
Beispiel habe ich auch ein Artikel
darüber geschrieben durch solche und ist
einfach ein Fachbegriff durch solche
heißt dass irgendwann einmal Klaus
Störer hat das x-mal erklärt
dass jeder irgendwann mal infiziert wird
unvermeidlich gewesen und deswegen hat
Signal keine durch solche Politik
gemacht sondern technell hat eine
Politik gemacht wo er einfach eine gute
Abwägung gemacht hat also zwischen
Infektionsschutz und zwischen dem
sozialen Leben den ökonomischen sozialen
und ähnlichen folgen das heißt also
Kinder und Jugendliche wurden in
Schweden zur Schule gehen das
Homeschooling betrifft höchstens gemäss
also ich glaube wir können es gibt noch
wahnsinnig viele aufzuarbeiten bei
diesem Thema ganz kurze Pause hier bei
8:15 Uhr wir sind gleich wieder für Sie
da wir freuen uns wenn Sie bei uns
bleiben Sie abgezockt oder reingelegt
das ist also eine Verzehnfachung jetzt
melden unsere Reporter kümmern sich um
Ihren Fall
für Sie